[Music]
all right so I was just fired from
Saturday Night Live it's not even the
worst thing that happened to me this
summer though because in June a man's
ponytail touched my mouth so that's
what's really been keeping me up at
night where was it before I don't know
somewhere pretty wet cheesy sir just
gonna flick that around on a subway okay
you have a radius it happened in New
York New York is too crowded there's so
many people there's even more rats I saw
a rat run over a woman's foot the other
day and she screamed and then the rat
went down the gutter and her husband was
like you're okay you're fine the rat is
gone then the rat came back out of the
gutter as if to say I say when it's fine
I ran these streets I've been thinking
so much about comedy lately I think I
know exactly why I do it I can pinpoint
the second I had to do it it's when I
was seven years old and I saw my dad
smash a possum with a sledgehammer and
then I just thought well I'm probably
going to need to talk about that
I don't think I should keep this memory
inside of my body this is what happened
I was seven I grew up in the woods in
Iowa and I saw it's a place I saw a
possum in our garage and I was just like
well you ain't sure I still be here so I
went inside and I woke up my dad who was
sleeping and I was like dad there's a
possum in the garage and it's eating all
the cat food and I did not know how
angry that would make a dad
turns out dad's hate it when possums get
into the cat food
it's ins into a blind rage to where you
as a seven year old start to think I bet
there's more going on in this guy's life
right now than just the current possum
cat food situation cause it's an
overreaction because he handled this
news by not putting any clothes on no
time possum in the cafe sprinting to the
garage grabbing the nearest weapon which
was a sledgehammer and then just
destroying a possum in front of his baby
boy he knew I was there and did not give
a courtesy look away child
he just did it and the aftermath shocked
both of us they shot my dad on account
of all the possum that got on his body
and then it shocked me because I was
seven years old and just had the thought
of well I made that murder happen this
possum blood is on my tiny hands next
time I will not tell on the possum I
will just go up to and be like oh hey
bro you're gonna want to get out of here
cuz the guy who lives inside is the
maniac stick to the wood pile it's not
my dad's fault that shocked to me so
much I was not a tough little kid like I
had a Furby way too long like a Furby is
this weird robot hamster owl most girls
my age hat me too I was gonna get rid of
it but I was like Willy taught it
English so I kept it and everyone as a
junior in high school I brought a girl
home after school one time but before
went in my room I was like one second I
forgot to make my bed and I went into my
room and I put my fur be in the closet
underneath a bunch of clothes and was
just like Shh
and then I brought the girl into my room
and things started going great and I
made her laugh really hard but her laugh
woke up the Furby in my closet
so just out of nowhere came it's time to
play she was like what was that
and I just scrambled and was like that's
where my family keeps her baby she's
like I don't know that sounded like a
Furby with fresh batteries thank you
guys so much
[Applause]
you